in the beginning all the legacy players
wanted nothing to do with this and a lot
of my time was focused on bitcoin
because that was really the only liquid
true asset they would even have a
conversation about
all the billionaire investors not
interested all the big wall street banks
not interested all the
you know institutional investors not
interested
almost
to a t
the best in the world
have changed their mind
they continued to get new information
and they changed their mind
and now some of them are the largest
investors in the industry
and so there's a level of intelligence
and intellectual humility it takes to
get new information and change your mind
the people who haven't changed their
mind for the most part not everyone but
for the most part
historically they haven't been very good
investors that's interesting and so they
just have this rigid
way of thinking
and regardless of the technology
evolution regardless of what happens in
the market they just have that rigid you
know kind of adherence to a framework
and so to me like that's been one of the
biggest investing lessons is
i talked to that guy
he wasn't like
he gave me a 12-minute meeting he
literally
nice to meet you i basically took the
meeting because somebody else i know
told me i should meet with you but like
i gotta go to lunch right
to now you're a huge investor in this
stuff and you're out and you're talking
about it and you're explaining it to
people etc
in two years what happened
oh you're not religious about your
ideas you're not religious about uh
having to be right
instead he said no it reached a point
where it was very obvious that the
macroeconomic environment was going to
continue to be crazy people were going
to want to hold this asset i understood
how it worked and so i changed my mind
by the way i've been an idiot if i
didn't change my mind yeah the only way
to live like that to me is my core life
thesis it's like i'm not interested in
being right i'm interested in
identifying the right answer faster than
anybody else
yeah building your self-esteem around
being right is a trap and most people
fall into it but that's really
interesting
it's also um
if you think about uh
trends and like identifying the right
answer
a lot of times if you were to go ask
like venture capitalists have to a lot
of times understand technology
innovation they also have to kind of
extrapolate out really really kind of uh
parabolic type growth etc
and the best way to do that is actually
not to think about it
right it's not to say you know what
airbnb is going to go from
no
locations
to globally dominant in five years
it's impossible to see that world the
guy has air mattresses on his kitchen
how is he gonna go become a globally
dominate company
uber has black cars driving around san
francisco how are they going to go
literally convince people not to buy
cars and instead use their service
that sounds insane at the time
but what you can do is you can basically
identify people who
have some future vision of the world
that
is different
and if successful will end up actually
being incredibly valuable so kind of
different and right right
and what you find is that's why venture
capitalists make so many bets
is because they're building a
probabilistic outcome
okay if i make 10 of these bets
four of them are actually gonna work the
four will pay for the six losers and all
i need to go do find is you know 10
crazy people who think that they can
change the world right
now
sure not everyone invests that way but
what you start to realize is
rather than try to predict it yourself
finding the people who know some secret
or know some you know future vision of
the world that they're going to go build
and create
ends up being a way easier way to
predict the future than actually sitting
there and like pontificating about you
know i think nfts are going to be
whatever in january did anyone think nft
one nft platform would sell three
billion dollars worth no way no way
now one thing i know that you don't
predict the future but that i it's the
only thing that gives me hesitation so
you're whatever famously like 95 percent
of your liquid assets are in bitcoin
um i'm way way way way way less than
that but my comfort it started with i'll
just do one percent and then i was like
well that felt good how about two and
then that was five and now it's like you
know i'm pacing ten
so
about ten percent right now that's what
i'm pacing i'll be there probably well i
guess if we dip really hard then i'll
race to that
uh if we don't just keep dollar cost
averaging but i already sort of planted
seeds with my wife i might be
comfortable at 25
so uh
yeah that i've really sort of adjusted
my thinking on that but the one thing
that gives me pause is
you've talked about bitcoin is going to
become the global reserve currency i
don't think
that governments go down without a fight
yeah so
global reserve currency uh first of all
is like a term that everyone talks about
but
what is a global reserve currency right
um there's two ways to look at this one
is the legacy terminology of global
reserve currency which is the most
dominant military basically puts the uh
the currency you know in place and then
enforces that across the world the
dollar is pro you know pretty good way
to you said as an example
every economy has a reserve asset
the us economy is based on the u.s
geographic uh players right people
within the u.s geography
and the reserve asset is the us dollar
if you go to mexico
the mexican economy has a reserve asset
at the peso et cetera and you go through
the world this is true
there's an economy though that has been
created it's actually the largest
economy in the world and it doesn't have
a reserve assets the internet the
digital economy does not care about
where you physically are geography does
not matter it's unhinged from the
geography
what's the reserve asset of the digital
economy
well
most people would say well i use dollars
right that that seems to be one of the
more popular ones
but that's because we live in the
developed western world
people on the internet in india don't
use dollars
right
they use their local currency and you go
around the world and you see this
what if we all just used one currency
and all the units were the same
okay that'd be interesting
and so the reason why i say that it is
going to be a global reserve currency is
i actually don't think it's nearly as
competitive with the fiat currencies as
people think it is
because
ultimately what happens is
the digital store of value i want to
protect my assets
and so what we're moving towards is a
multi-currency world right right now you
and i live in a single currency world
you get paid in dollars saving dollars
invest in dollars and then you also pay
taxes in dollars if you want to go to
somebody else's single currency world
mexico you have to convert your dollars
to pesos to operate within the mexican
uh economy for the most part
well when you make that conversion it's
actually very difficult
you go to the bank and you try to
withdraw it it's got to be large sums
or you go to like a currency exchanger
at the airport they rip you off right
like it sucks
what happens if all of a sudden the
friction and the cost of
transacting between currencies or
switching the switching cost goes to
zero
and now i get paid in dollars
and with a click of a button i can
change my dollars into pesos or into
bitcoin or into a digital euro et cetera
well
now the technology is the exact same
the only difference the only competition
between the currencies is at the
monetary policy standpoint they're all
digital currencies so the digital dollar
digital peso and bitcoin are literally
all the same technology wise in that
steady state
but there's competition at the top layer
at the monetary at the monetary policy
layer what is monetary policy
all fiat currencies have the same
monetary policy
on a
structure standpoint
inflationary currencies okay meaning
that there's constantly more printed of
it it's got a variable monetary policy
meaning that uh it constantly changes
sometimes they're expanding sometimes
they're contracting but the reason why
the dollar is guaranteed to lose value
is because they have to continue to
create more of it right same with the
peso same with the euro etc
so if you actually take all the fiat
currencies and you put them in a bucket
there is a non-consensus or a different
currency structure which is bitcoin for
example and so if it ends up being right
it's gonna be wildly valuable it's
non-consensus then right
but two is
if i'm looking to store value from i'm
trying to save
i'm not going to save in the fiat
structure regardless of the currency
doesn't matter dollars euros yen
whatever
i'm going to put it into an asset where
it protects my purchasing power
and if the switching cost is zero and i
can switch back and forth very easily so
you can see a world where my employer
pays me in dollars
it auto converts into bitcoin i set it
there and then i gotta pay my taxes in
dollars i convert back into dollars and
i pay
well
i'm saving in bitcoin i'm storing value
in bitcoin what do people do
well historically maybe i had to buy
real estate to do that so my employer
paid me in dollars took the dollars i
converted it into real estate i sat
there and then all of a sudden i needed
money to pay my taxes i could sell the
real estate get it and pay it back now
that's a ridiculous
you know order of events if i'm simply
going to use it as a saving mechanism to
then pay my taxes you know later this
year
because there's
cost there's time lapse
etc but there's no difference between
doing that with real estate or doing it
with bitcoin
it's just now all of a sudden i can do
it instantaneously i can do it with a
digital asset that protects my
purchasing power and the switching cost
is zero essentially
and so when we move to a multi-currency
world
actually in some crazy way the fiat
currencies may become more valuable
and this is uh not everyone agrees with
this i'm gonna say i'm so intrigued
it's like the restaurant problem right
if i put a restaurant on a intersection
it's the only restaurant it gets let's
say 10 people a day if i put a
restaurant across the street many times
people will say oh that's competition
now that first restaurant is going to
suffer
if i put a third one there people say oh
my god that first one's screwed a fourth
one oh my god the first one is out of
business
in reality what happens is all the
studies show
when you build density at the
intersection
everyone actually gets more traffic
because that that becomes known as
restaurant intersection that's where all
the restaurants are yeah i'm hungry i
don't know let's just go down there
we'll figure something out and so
actually the first one benefits from
having the others move in there
there's two arguments when it comes to
bitcoin in the fiat currencies one is
that they're in direct competition with
each other bitcoin wins fiat currencies
lose game over right and in that
scenario governments absolutely do not
want this to happen the governments that
embrace the technology that ends up
being the winner first will drastically
outperform those that are last to adopt
it right
the second one is this argument of
no actually a multi-currency raw all
boats rise together
now
you know i talked earlier about i don't
want to be a market predictor
what i find right now is as technologies
are being digitized it actually
increases the accessibility of them for
people around the world
so take that second example i'm in
venezuela the bolivia r ends up getting
devalued away i know i gotta get out
really really hard for me to get dollars
i can try through the bank but there's
limitations i'm worried about
confiscation off by the government etc
the black market is really pricey uh in
terms of it cost me a lot to actually go
buy it and it can actually be physically
dangerous
so why do i want dollars well there's
safety in the dollar in my mind there's
stability there that's the best currency
my currency sucks this one's great let
me go buy this one
okay dollars are hard to get i'll get
gold well hard to find can be physically
dangerous could be confiscated etc
okay what can i do on the internet
if all of a sudden i think let's say
bitcoin's too volatile for me
i want dollars but the dollar isn't
digitized on these platforms but china
takes their currency and they create a
digital currency
it's better than nothing
so what do i do i buy the digital
currency of china and it's just a pure
accessibility thing so i think
ultimately the incentive is that
everything will be digitized right
you'll get digital dollars to your euro
yen etc and some of that will be because
people believe that there's some sort of
uh internal domestic advantage to it but
also some of it's going to be just
simply the game theory of we have to
digitize our currency so it's accessible
to people around the world and so we can
drive more adoption more value
but the second that everyone has digital
wallets
everything becomes a currency right
how many people
say to themselves oh i own that piece of
real estate i need to sell it to get
dollars then go buy something
well what happens when i can just
take the real estate and buy directly
the asset i don't have to go to the
common unit of account of a dollar
all the technology is the same
the value just is different
and so you get this really weird world
where like i don't know what's going to
happen in the future
but you can clearly articulate two or
three different versions
and
in every single one of those versions
bitcoin specifically is valuable
so bitcoin is valuable if it goes head
to head with the fiat currencies bitcoin
is valuable if the fiat currencies
benefit you know and all currencies end
up occurring more and bitcoin is
valuable if all of a sudden every asset
is a currency and you can interchange
them freely
so from my standpoint it was
actually the least risky thing i could
do personally was to buy bitcoin
and i always say that i sit at the
intersection of two very very different
worlds
when i talk to you know friends on wall
street or these large asset managers and
stuff they're like you are insane
having 95 of your net worth in this
thing
and i say
sure
but i think you're insane for having 95
of your net worth in dollars or in
dollar denominated assets right
so we see eye to eye on insanity it's
just two different assets
if i go talk to uh there's particularly
young people in crypto that are on the
edges of innovation and really kind of
pushing pushing the pace of this new
stuff
they're like dude
you are the least risk tolerant person
i've ever met like you just hold boomer
coin
right like bitcoin doesn't do anything
and so how can it be that the same asset
viewed by
the youngest most kind of
forward-thinking innovative people is
seen as
the most conservative but by the oldest
most successful is seen as the most
risky
it's actually probably where you want to
sit
right is because you're you're uh taking
the two worlds and you're kind of
meeting them in the middle
and so
when you ask
about like allocations and all stuff it
i always ask you what are you optimizing
for
i basically built a venn diagram early
on and i said okay what is the thing
that i think is most likely to be here a
hundred years from now right my plan is
to hand bitcoin to my grandkids okay so
he said it needs to be around 100 years
the durability of it and also what is
the thing that has a very attractive
return compared to traditional assets
bitcoins compounded at 200 annually for
a decade that's crazy pretty crazy right
so if it's durable and it has an
attractive return compared to
traditional assets
i'm gonna go get a lot of that and if i
denominate my net worth in it
and my life like my financial life in it
it actually changes psychologically
spending money
because it's one thing if i say hey
you're going to go spend a depreciating
asset to buy a house or buy a car or buy
whatever might as well it's going down
to value anyway you're financially
incentivized to do it
right he's literally he's going to lose
value so you better get rid of it
if i say to you hey
you're going to buy something with an
appreciating asset
that is likely to be worth more in the
future than it is today and i also need
to thank yourself what am i buying
do i need it is it gonna is it an
investment is gonna be worth more than
what this is gonna be worth you start to
ask yourself a little some of the
questions you might not have otherwise
asked
and so it's it's um one of these things
where like i basically just throw my
hands up and i said look
the world is changing at a rapid pace i
spend all day on this stuff and i can't
keep up
um
it will look very different 25 years
from now than it does today
uh
and how lucky are we
that we get to live here that we're
talking about it that we see the
opportunities
and you know what you and i will make a
bunch of investment decisions some of
them will work some of them won't
my guess is that by
picking the right industry that has a
massive tailwind behind it
we would have to be really really really
really stupid and then make really
really really stupid decisions
and we probably still will be okay
because you're simply it's like saying
oh i invested in the internet in the 90s
i mean you had to be an absolute idiot
to not somehow somewhere end up better
off after investing the internet than
before
i think the same thing's true here so
you know you can make optimizations all
that but at the end of the day anyone
who's paying attention to this stuff i
think it's gonna be fine
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]